CHRIS ANDERSON: What you
want is authenticity.
You want people who
care about something.
And even if half stammer
their way through a talk,
if you're learning
something, that is fantastic.
JASON WU: There is
something that's
so beautiful about
natural material.
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON: I decided
to sort of dig deep and make
the book very much based on all
the latest science about sleep.
WILL SMITH: Dave would
say, dude, come here-- cut,
cut-- and just cut her hair off.
I was like (SCREAMING).
CEDRIC VILLANI: In
most other countries,
it doesn't work this way.
And you need to train
mathematicians from young age.
KARI BYRON: Every
TV show you look at,
you see actual women represented
in smart scientific fields.
DANA SHULTZ: Then a
little red pepper flake,
which I usually prefer.
JOSEPH ELLWANGER: The movement
for justice is never complete.
It's never ended.
RYAN REYNOLDS: So I'm thrilled
to talk about "Deadpool"
because I never thought
"Deadpool" would exist.
It's been an 11-year thing,
and it's the worst relationship
I've ever been in.
But we're happily married now.
And we're expecting.
ELLEN DEGENERES: Because I
think if anyone knows my story,
it is I had to
just keep swimming.
My life has been a
lot of challenges
and a lot of different
curves and roadblocks.
LUPITA NYONG'O: What was
instilled in me was this idea
that you do your best
exactly where you are.
Like you challenge yourself.
You compete with yourself before
you compete with anybody else.
SPEAKER 12: Ladies
and gentlemen,
please join me in giving
Andrea Bocelli a warm welcome
to Google.
[SINGING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MANA: And one of my
daughters asked me, hey,
when was it built and all this.
And I told her, go to our
friend Google and search it.
PEDRO DUQUE:
[NON ENGLISH SPEECH].
TAKAKO: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
MICHAEL GREGER: Let
me share with you
what's been called the best
kept secret in medicine.
DAVA NEWMAN: Be
sure we know what
technology do you
think we really
needed to work on for Station.
JOHN CHO: I just want
to note that I'm pretty
sure Sulu's taking a selfie.
SPEAKER 19: Would you make
a Googler's dream come true
and take a picture with
me crimping DJ's hair?
CANDACE CAMERON-BURE:
Yes, totally.
NILE RODGERS: Hey, I'm
Nile Rodgers and thanks
for watching Talks at Google.